I was invited by YouTube to interview
some politicians and business leaders
who were attending the Apex Summit in
San Francisco and I showed up with a
pile of exams that I gave them as a way
to hear their thoughts on education so
here's what they had to say I actually
have here this year's je exam from India
if I can give that to you just for a
second don't worry I won't ask you to
solve any problems well speaking of
Australian education I have here just
for a little bit of fun the latest new
Wales economics exam for the HSC high
school so I wanted to just hand it to
you as an example of the kind of things
that stress students out in the US at
the moment and just see if it brought up
any I guess emotions of of what it was
like to sit in exam or it brings back
any stress in any way or or any other
thoughts and see if it jogs any memories
of of your time at school it does is
this the joint the IIT joint entrance
exam or okay so I took a bunch of exams
to graduate from high schol school but
this was uh these types of questions do
bring back a lot of memory um uh it is
stressful to look at these at these
problems but I do think it goes back to
you know taking a deep breath and what
are the tools that I can use to find the
answer the um I've said a few of these
over the years I did high school
economics the textbooks uh in the
Queensland education system at the time
were written by Brown
and you know how we manag to navigate
the global financial crisis without
going into recession I put that down to
a quand high school education using
Browns the textbooks on macro and micro
but these are fairly standard questions
no they don't excite anxiety in me of
any particular order of
magnitude um but I think normally in
preparing for anything um there's going
to be a level of anxiety in making sure
you you've um done your homework yes
it's amazing that you found that though
it's a very difficult one I'd say that
yeah very CH I wouldn't pass this
without doing a little more study myself
but exams like this one they have a lot
of questions and it's very high stakes
very competitive often math exams are
testing memorization or you know things
that perhaps don't seem like they would
ever be practical do you think if you
you can remember back to any of the math
exams you took did those prepare you
well for for your job now or for the
real world what I can tell you from my
own experience and you know it's
interesting I I had my own experience
obviously my wife and I talk about our
own uh high school and college
experiences and then we see it in you
know in our children it's very different
and I don't think it's actually
necessarily just a pure difference of
Educational Systems I also think the
generation the decades make a difference
too in terms of approach to it and I
would say that there is something to be
said for um the ideas that come from
actually having more more of that sort
of blank canvas approach as opposed to
like here's like the methodology that
you have to go through not having that
time pressure also and so I think I
would say that it's probably a balance
but I see the value in sort of that more
open-ended approach I I think balance is
is what we're doing we're walking the
line between hindering students and
crushing their soul with with exams like
this and actually helping them learn
effectively right actually getting the
substance is important as well
memorizing remembering that aspect helps
me really well right now as a blind at
right I have to remember a lot in my
mind when I'm entering into giving a
speech or talk or dialogue that thinking
and math actually has translated into my
work education for me uh has been a
preparation for life there's very little
uh that I haven't that I've studied I
should say in Chinese language and
Chinese history that I don't use on an
almost daily basis because of where
China is in the world today like this
morning I was doing an interview
uh about um shiin ping Summit with
President Biden uh look asked my staff
to find me the uh the Chinese readout of
the meeting we couldn't find it quickly
so I was reading the Chinese text um and
to see whether certain word usages had
changed or not from previous Chinese
statements that's just one example of
the work I do where you draw directly on
what I learned back then have you
noticed a difference in how different
countries treat education
maybe well I've spent actually most of
my adult life in Asia my kids were with
me so they lived and went to school in
China and then South Africa and
Singapore before we returned to the us
about four years ago so I I have seen
sort of up close how education differs
in some of those countries one thing
that is particularly true in parts of
Asia that I think is really wonderful is
that the teaching profession is really
revered and respected the position of
being a teacher is something that people
really aspire to I wish that we would do
more in the United States also to to
really lift up our teachers in that way
I really agree with that I think you
know the way we treat teachers means a
lot and says a lot about what we value
as a society and yeah I've even covered
some you know exams from India and China
before and even the people the students
who top those exams in the country
become many celebrities for a while
there're you know this person has got
the highest score everyone knows their
name so I think that that's a culture
that I think can help you know Foster
learning and and Foster people wanting
to do well so you've studied in more
than just Australia you went on to
Oxford and elere and you've been all
around the world um through your jobs
but have you seen a difference in how
perhaps different countries treat
education well uh demonstrably so each
of them has their own culture of uh of
learning but uh I think there is a
certainly a tradition of academic rigor
about a college level education here
there is a greater emphasis on the
quantitative even within the social
sciences than you see in the um Anglo
Australian universities it's my
understanding that you did a bit of your
education in the US and a bit in India
so I'd love to ask you how did those
educational experiences differ did you
find that those two countries treated
education differently H that's a really
interesting question probably one of the
most interesting questions I've ever
gotten it was uh a bit of a shock for me
moving from you know Michigan to India
part of this probably had to do with my
interest but it was very science and
math focused that's what my interest
also happen to be so let me just put it
this way by the time I got done with
high school in India I felt very very
prepared uh for college I came out right
actually right here to Stanford for for
college and I was uh I was a very
well-prepared freshman let's put it that
way you know the Indian system's pretty
intense I had a conversation with a A
friend of mine the other day and we were
just talking about all the textbooks
that we had to use back back in the day
um uh and so you said your your physics
right so like Resnik and holiday like
those those the pages of those books are
still seared in my brain from uh from my
time time in India all right as a last
question for I'll let you go do you have
any advice um for students perhaps
taking their exams at the moment on how
to handle stress and and what they're
going through for me one thing was
confidence is a big part of it but also
understanding that school might be the
most important thing right now but later
on in life every single experience you
have that you're taking through exams
and schools will be an amazing learned
lesson for later on in life so things
turn out for the best and always try to
choose a path have education path that's
align to your interest and to your value
and to your potential that will make a
huge difference well thank you very much
for talking with me yeah I enjoyed the
conversation happy to do and I heard a
rumor that you wanted to touch my hair
I'll pass it over to you oh my God you
pass it over to you oh wow just go just
below my knees yeah thank you for
watching and thank you to my patreon
supporters a special shout out to
today's patreon cats of the day grape
and
ditto